- I feel like I'm a little kid.
But I'm not, I'm an adult
woman and I can do this.
(upbeat piano)
My name is Emily, I'm new to BuzzFeed,
and I really want to
make some new friends.
So to do that I've decided
to challenge myself
to sit with strangers every
day during lunch this week.
I'm equal parts excited
and a bit terrified.
It may seem easy to some people
but for me personally,
talking to new people
is really difficult.
Even though I knew people were probably
going to be nice to me, I
was still a sweaty mess.
It's gonna be fine.
It's gonna be really good, alright.
I'm gonna ask these cute boys
if they don't mind me joining them.
One second.
Do you mind if I join you?
Is that okay?
Awesome, what's your name?
- I'm Lewis.
- Lewis, nice to meet you.
- We've met.
- [Lewis] What's the premise of this?
- Premise is that I have difficulty
making new friends a bit.
- [Lewis] Do you have
friends just in real life?
- Yes.
- [Lewis] So the problem isn't with you.
- The prob, it might be with
like my first impression.
Like right now I'm sweating a lot.
- [Lewis] How do you think
you're doing right now?
- Right now I'm like
scared because you're like
very pretty and very good at eye contact.
- [Lewis] Oh stop.
- And like, I already
messed up 'cause I like
forgot that I met you, and I'm sorry.
- No no, it's okay.
I had a different haircut,
I wasn't wearing a beanie.
- Thank you for taking the
time to talk to me, thank you.
So that went pretty well.
I see two people but
they're like in conversation
and I don't want to interrupt,
so just like hang back for a second.
And I'm gonna go approach.
Okay, bye.
- Hey guys, I'm filming a video
where I hang out in
the canteen with people
I don't know during lunchtime.
- Okay.
- Can I hang out with
you for a little bit?
- [Both] Sure.
- I'm Emily. So nice to meet you.
What do you guys do at BuzzFeed?
- I'm a podcast host.
- That's really cool.
- Have you heard of
See Something Say Something?
- Wait, oh my gosh, that's you?
(laughing)
sorry, I've only heard your
voice, I haven't seen your face.
- That's me.
- So like, working at
BuzzFeed, like everyone's
really diverse and cool, and like
part of the reason for doing this video
is like selfishly I
want to talk to everyone
and this like gives me
an excuse to be like hey,
can I bombard your totally
personal conversation
and just be like hi, I'm Emily.
I'm Emily, do you guys mind
if I eat lunch with you today?
- [Woman] Yeah, we mind.
No, it's okay.
- Hey, oh.
Hey.
- Hey.
- Do you guys mind if I
join you for a little bit?
- Oh yeah, no worries.
- Hey, is it alright if I join you?
- Yeah.
- Go for it.
- Yay.
- We were just talking about The Bachelor.
- Oh my gosh.
So what are your opinions on The Bachelor?
What are your lives like?
What are you up to?
- [Blonde Woman] Oh my gosh,
what are our lives like.
- Wow what are our lives like.
- Is that a good small talk?
Once we got the ball
rolling small talk turned
into regular conversation.
It started to relax more.
I talked about everything with everyone
from buying homes,
did you just buy a property?
- I did, yeah.
- [Emily] That's badass.
To our favorite podcasts.
- To like Radiolab, to This American Life,
to My Favorite Murder.
- I love My Favorite Murder.
- So good.
- [Emily] Or even how your
pets sexuality is a bit creepy.
- Well I took away her sex organs, so.
I took them away and I said,
you don't know what this is.
You'll never know.
- Why did you choose us?
- Because I've wanted to talk to you.
(laughter)
Thank you.
Yeah I was like too
nervous to eat, it's fine.
Have a good day.
(fanfare)
it's really hard to eat in
front of people you don't know.
Things I've found out this week.
Let's eat lunch when
it's not being filmed.
If you want, yeah, real cool.
Hey Aaron.
- This girl's really cool,
this lunch was a great experience.
- Oh no, thanks, bye.
I finally ate in front of people
so I'm excited about that.
I still have a lot of sandwich left
but you know, I'll go find a corner.
I felt really proud of
myself for doing this.
I was nervous every time
I approached a new table
but I still did it.
The connections I made
doing this were genuine.
Afterwords, people came up to
me and still wanted to talk
even though there was no
camera around to film it.
Overall this was a great experience.
I had awkward moments, funny moments,
even some failure moments.
I recommend this experience.
I want you guys to try it out too,
get out of your bubble,
tell me how it goes
in the comments below.
That went really well, I am
stress sweating really bad.